you know I I hate to say I told you so
but uh I missed this story when it came
out on the fifth we're gonna go over it
tonight I talked about it earlier today
Owen Shroyer is being targeted by the
doj they want 120 days in prison why
speech
Owen Shroyer a pundit personality and
journalist for Infowars
said some things
and uh for the things he said the doj
says he should go to prison for it and
this is what I said was gonna happen I
said now they're going after they go
after Trump they go after his lawyers
the next people in line are going to be
the pundits who are advocating for or
encouraging people on January 6. first
person in line Owen Shroyer now a few a
few important details he did not go into
the capital the Infowars team had a
permit to have a rally outside the
Capitol in a different area Owen Shroyer
was on Capitol grounds this is the
initial pretext they get to charge him
he pleads guilty they then say in the
charging in the sentencing document the
prosecutor says because of his speech
before during and after the event
he should get this amount of time in
prison
it's not a one for one to what I was
exactly describing but it's basically
the opening the door the Midway point a
guy said some things about January 6
encouraged people he challenged the the
established order and for that he should
go to prison we're going to talk about
that we do have a lot of good news
though and the reason why they're
getting so heavy-handed
CNN's got a poll out Trump's winning
if the election were held today Trump
wins
yeah it's within the margin of error but
he's beating Biden and CNN says never in
the 2020 cycle did they have polls that
showed this level of uh uh uh this high
probability for Donald Trump you also
have a Yankees game a banner wasn't for
that said Trump or death so I certainly
hope not
but it's getting uh it's getting crazy
out there before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com click
timcast X IRL Miami and uh pick up your
tickets today to come hang out with us
live in Miami at our live show October 6
6 p.m at 10 30 p.m we got a bunch of
free stuff for you when you show up we
got Public Square is sponsoring it and
we're going to have Patrick Bet David
Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and of course
me Tim Poole lukakowski and cross and
we'll all be there we hope to see you
there we got a pre-show we've got an
after show q a for all of you who hang
out and stick around in the audience to
talk to all of us ask us questions it's
going to be really exciting don't forget
to also go to timcast.com click join us
become a member we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you tonight at 10 p.m where you as
members can actually submit questions
and call into the show to talk to us and
ask us questions directly you got to be
a member for at least six months or sign
up today at the 25 per month level
granting you instant access it kind of
sucks but this is like our gatekeeping
method to make sure creepy weirdo
stalkers and you know people who are
trying to harass us don't come in and
waste our time but again timcast.com
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Martha Bueno
hello good evening yeah who are you what
do you do so thank you so much for
having me I'm Martha Bueno I am a
liberty activist and I am the first
person in the United States of used only
fans as a campaign as a method to
campaign
um I am also a um entrepreneur in what
way though is the question how how did I
use only fans yeah I put political
content on only fans I it was very
G-rated however because the media people
are like what are you saying are you
saying you did adults coming the spice
level was about green pepper oh green
pepper it was spicy
right on right on uh so what are you
doing now uh currently I just launched
our good it is a new way to consume
Delta 88 the um or in other cannabinoids
and uh you can check us out at
ourgood.com right on thanks for hanging
out we got Phil Avanti hello everybody
my name is philibonti I am lead singer
of The Heavy Metal and All That Remains
and I am an anti-communist encounter
revolutionary Mr last week we had a
great episode with uh thank you Jackson
Hinkle we'll see you again soon you know
hey I found I just read recently that
people want to polish the Statue of
Liberty of all that green it's green
because it's basically um oxidized
copper and if you polish it down it's
going to be like a bronze copper shiny
would you guys suggest putting tax money
into that would that be a good Public
Works project I actually don't hate the
idea and I think that uh New Jersey and
New York should actually compete for
who's going to actually clean it up
because Jersey's always saying oh you
know Ellis Island or I mean uh Liberty
Islands in in New Jersey it's not New
York blah blah so let them fight about
it and then whoever cleans it gets to
have it for a year T-Mobile T-Mobile
wins the bid and it's the T-Mobile
Statue of Liberty I hope that doesn't
happen that I really hope that doesn't
happen I think it's fine that it's green
I don't know whatever yeah it looked
cool the picture that they showed of it
was like wow it could be shiny that'd be
cool the tweet that he was harder the
Tweet when they were talking about it he
was talking about like doing it as an
idea of like rejuvenating American
bringing American Spirit back and Etc
and there are times where those kind of
policies or those kind of uh things can
can inspire people I don't know if it's
a great idea I don't know if it's if
it's going to do a whole lot but I don't
I don't think it's a you know it's not a
horrible idea it's kind of neat let me
know in the chat we also have Carter
banks in tonight what's up guys felon in
for Kellen he's filling in for surge I
think we should keep it green for now
for old time's sake but for old time's
sake technical times that would be
polished
I like green I don't know all right well
let's jump into this first story it's
from none other than everyone's favorite
Media Matters for America ah yes trash
can I actually I actually really like
this article it says Alex Jones claims
Infowars host Owen Shroyer was charged
for free speech that's it they don't
insult Alex Jones they don't write
anything they literally just post a
quote and a video of Alex Jones which uh
I will play a bit for you here right now
I think uh now this deals with Owen and
and this deals with the rest of January
six people where their lawyers are like
we don't want you to antagonize the
system
we don't want you to sit there and do a
bunch of stuff let us try to not get
them in prison I'm like well I want to
defend them I want to talk about it well
it's up to them they want help or not
and and Owen's a Smart Cookie but
they're trying to put Owen in jail in
prison they fouled last night he sent us
next week
goes to DC
and
I didn't cover it but the Gateway pundit
did Breaking DC prosecutors seek 120
days in prison for Owen Shroyer for
speaking out against Stone election 2020
that's not just
the Gateway upon its headline
I have overhead shot please right here
the charging document the feds put
forward here it is we actually have that
as well and so in the charging document
I'm not going to read through the whole
thing
they basically say before January 6 on
January 6th and after January 6th Owen
schroyer had said things that
incited people
and uh for that they are seeking this
sentence the criminal charge against
them is not for speech it's for uh being
on the capitol grounds but they're
arguing that he is the reason people
stormed the capital
they highlight this be a part of History
fight for Trump and it shows people
outside the capital uh Alex Jones and
Owen with bullhorns
and if you scroll down
I'll jump down to uh right before they
get to their their recommendations they
go on to mention uh let's see uh I want
to try and find the specific portion May
they go on a mention after the fact
August
so this is for his speech that they are
seeking to put him in jail
when I said that the next people they'd
come for would be pundits I didn't I
didn't mean like outright it would be oh
and sure anything like that there are
people who are not in the capital we're
not in the capital grounds who I am
referring to and there are people who
are not even in DC who I am referring to
I even said like prominent cable
personalities were in Communications
with Trump legals team who who pushed
the narrative prominent personalities
many of whom got sued they're gonna come
after them next but Owen schroyer is in
between he Not only was there on the
ground he didn't go in the building but
he was also someone at their seeking a
prison sentence for over speech he made
after the fact
I blame Obama
yeah it wasn't uh because the precedent
for going after journalists was set with
uh Snowden and with uh Assange and then
the Obama Administration went after
James Rosen so the idea that this is the
first time no this is something that's
been in motion for a long time and
there's a lot of people people around
this table and and other pundits and
stuff that have have been vocal about
how it's a bad thing that you know
Snowden hasn't been uh pardoned and
Assange hasn't been pardoned and it's a
bad thing that that Rosen went to jail
and the Democrats Frozen actually went
to jail or I'm sorry that they uh they
went after him we've had him on the show
I'm pretty sure yeah I was here and he
was talking about you know they
wiretapped him and blah blah and uh you
know
the fact that we have allowed the
government to get away with it is why it
continues now the situation we're in
right here if this does happen and he
goes to jail for speech
it's only going to be worse they're not
there's not going to be someone that
says okay
that's enough
BS they're gonna be like all right that
worked the American people allowed it
this is a new power we have and we can
do this so let's go back in time let's
go back to when the when the bite
Administration targeted James Rosen a
journalist tried to put him in jail when
Obama uh charged whistleblowers and
journalists under the Espionage Act more
than any other president combined then
all the other presidents combined yeah
imagine going back then when we were
concerned about this and telling people
in 10 years
they're going to put a guy in jail
because he was on the capitol grounds
bullhorning
and then after the fact he said he said
he said stuff like to a certain degree
we should be proud of what we did that
day
he said something like he's he maintains
the election was stolen one of the
reasons they want him in jail is because
they said even after all this he still
maintains the election was stolen as if
he has to publicly change his opinion
yeah this is
this is Soviet level this is culture
Revolution level
communist authoritarianism welcome to
the Future and it happens very quickly
very quickly it goes from you're free to
you're not free
I mean look we're discussing 10 years
not even I mean and think about the past
few years think about where we were six
seven years ago and it's it's laughable
to me that there are people who are like
ah you're overreacting or you're you
know it's exaggerating or it's shot
content I'm like dude
I think the issue is that
everybody is standing in the middle of
the forest and when you tell them dude
you are in the middle of force like what
do you mean to cancel the trees like one
two three four five six seven eight nine
I'm like bro you can't tell where all
the other trees are because you're
standing in the middle of all of them
yeah you got to look at nine I mean 911
is like
you know when you see those buildings
fall in free fall I I most people can
understand it when they see the site
okay hold on nah like you want to talk
about you just jump slow boil way too
far that's the beginning of this
totalitarian seizure man I can't respect
that but you got to slow down a little
bit the way that the government you got
to talk about okay so we ended up in
this position with the ndaa the National
Defense authorization act 2010 or so
2000 I think that was 12. which gave the
indefinite which signed into law the
indefinite detention provision which is
an offshoot of what is effectively the
bush era expansion of authoritarianism
anti-terror policies and the expansion
of the creation of DHS which emerges out
of the Patriot Act which starts I
watched it happen in real time too it
was crazy and like I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm saying we gotta we gotta work
we gotta explain to people how we get
from point A to point B right this would
set like a precedent for that to be
acceptable if they were to pull that off
and now it is now now we're here when
when we talked in 2012 about the the
indefinite detention provision that
Obama signed into law the NDA provision
that says they could snatch you up in
the middle of the night without charge
or trial hold you on a military vessel
11 miles off the coast of this country
and rendition you
we were like that's scary and the
response to everybody is oh you're nuts
that's never gonna happen shut your
mouths because now we're at the point
where they're arresting journalists
they're arrested well they've been
targeting journalists that's the Obama
era around the same time going after a
Rosen Julian Assange that's that's an
informal assassination as far as I'm
concerned Owen Shroyer said bombastic
things outside the Capitol and for that
they want to go to prison this is the
next grain of sand they're going after
lawyers they're going after political uh
they're going after politicians it's not
just Trump They removed Coy Griffin in
New Mexico from the ballot this is well
beyond the point we are we are
potentially a couple years away from the
actual implementation of an indefinite
detention Act
the Trump and and I hate the fact that
this is so prescient now but Trump said
they're not coming after you or they're
not coming after me they're coming after
you I'm just in the way and I hate the
fact that it looks like that's the case
the idea that it's just Trump is
something that that I've been pushing
back against with Democrats specifically
shitlabs uh for a long time because they
think oh well Donald Trump is different
Donald Trump is different it's like
the thing that's different is the
behavior of the Democrats on the left
the influence of authoritarianism in the
United States on the left is undeniable
and the the fact that people have been
ignoring it or just saying no no it's
not true likely because they don't
believe it's true because they have
normal jobs and normal lives and they're
not steeped in this stuff like people
that do this stuff all the time but the
fact of the matter is
the federal government has never been
more authoritarian they're throwing
people in jail in the way that they did
like during the uh the Civil War and in
the 20s or no was it was it Wilson that
threw people in jail FDR threw people in
jail but it's back to the old you know
authoritarian government and that's not
acceptable they're iced and I said we've
said this a bunch I don't see the off
ramp if this is accepted
what's going to be next because it's not
going to be oh we're going to chill out
it would take someone in at the Democrat
Party with in power standing up and
saying we can't do this and there is no
one that even wants to they're all
enjoying it I think it's going to come
from us to be honest that's scary yeah
it is scary but you know what nobody's
coming to save you and you see this
everywhere where authoritarianism just
takes hold you know everybody's like
well we just need a savior and that's
why you get that charismatic leader that
comes in and destroys the country and
you know maybe that charismatic leader
that we need to save us As Trump but I
doubt it no he was in power before and
he did nothing for Julian Assange he did
nothing for Edwards Edward Snowden he
did nothing for Ross Albrecht he's done
nothing to change the situation that
we're in now he had the opportunity four
years was plenty yeah but there's nobody
else there is nobody else I agree with
you there's nobody else and at this
point it's Trump or nobody but we can't
expect that Trump is going to come save
us we have to understand that it's going
to come from us and it's going to come
from Americans number one understanding
history understanding where this is
going and then doing something about it
because they can't control us if we
don't allow them to you you were talking
earlier about uh Venezuela can you go
ahead and relate some of the things that
you were telling us about because this
is pre this is important now because
this is something that it's it's
possible that we're gonna have to worry
about we have got there are people that
that and I really do want you to do but
I want to say this first people that
that deny that there's a problem on the
left they need to go to urban areas and
talk to the P the political activists
the people that are on the ground
working with the with the communities
talk to them you go to you go to
Brooklyn there's DSA everywhere which is
the Democratic socialists of America
full of commies full of Communists and
and they're they're at the point where
they'll tell you about it so if you
don't mind go ahead and somehow it's
okay to be a communist in this country
like you would never call yourself
according to me you know let's let's
start from the beginning uh it wasn't
that long ago people don't realize this
that Venezuela was a wealthy capitalist
Nation absolutely so I wasn't born in
Venezuela because my mom hightailed it
back to the US to have me
um but I was I was taken to Venezuela
when I was nine days old and I lived
there until back and forth between the
us until I was 15. so you know I'm
however like my age old is how like long
this has been going on not even much
less I watched communism socialism enter
into Venezuela Venezuela was one of the
most prosperous nations in Latin America
before Venezuela it was Cuba which was
of course destroyed by the same ideology
and there's no way to talk about
Venezuela without talking about Cuba
because Fidel Castro the dictator of
Cuba trained Hugo Chavez
um in Cuba on how to do this you know
it's I I think people just assume that
it's easy to come into power and take
over
um and and it he did it in the very
similar ways to Castro so yeah it starts
very similarly and it's this class
Warfare it starts with the well you're
poor because that guy over there has
your money that guy over there it has
your your jobs and your opportunities
and you know you're poor because of them
so you see the class Warfare and that's
that's really where you know it started
like Dawning on me here in the US like
oh wait I've seen this before it's that
that and then it you know it Authority
come in and of course you can't you
your guns is the first thing they take
you know unfortunately here in the US we
have started to lose a little bit of our
our gun freedoms and I understand that
that's scary for some people but I I
disagree on that one it's actually not
true what uh gun rights have expanded
rapidly and exponentially over the past
two decades in ways that this country
is is it's been good right so uh DC
versus Heller the right to for
individuals to keep and bear arms
outside of their home was 2008. if you
look at the issuance of gun permits
there was not a single state that would
allow you to have a gun for the most
part back in the 80s it was it was
actually difficult to have guns now we
did have a different culture where
people had rifles and there was like gun
clubs in schools but uh in the past 20
years the expansion of individual
liberties and gun rights has been
exponential to the point where now I
think half the country is constitutional
carry to or or I'm sorry it's probably
safer to say uh uh open carry in more
than half the country which did not
exist 20 30 years ago what was it before
that when we didn't have to you need you
needed a permit and they wouldn't give
it to you when did we need a permit so
even with the Second Amendment they St
you you still had back in the day let's
like let's go back to the frontier era
in New York they didn't allow you to
have guns Second Amendment said to the
right to keep and bear arms and it was
in your house basically and uh uh
famously you'll look at you know old uh
old westerns or whatever the Trope was
the American history was you'd go into a
town and they could order you to turn
over your weapons
now we're in an era and and again for
the most part people would carry guns
because you're out in the middle of
nowhere no one can enforce anything
anyway
but we get into this modern era uh you
go back to the 1900s we get the NFA
early 1900s I think it was like the 20s
and they start expanding Rapid Control
of firearms and making it harder and
harder
it's actually uh if you look at the map
of the right to keep and bear arms
without a permit the government can't
question you started to emerge after the
80s so we're actually doing really
really well that's amazing maybe that's
why they're going after the first
amendment instead of the second one they
are because you kind of but you kind of
need to get rid of the first one too in
order to you know go after the second
one then well I I they're going after
the Second Amendment for sure they're
not they're never stopping but they are
losing and I think it's important for
everyone to understand
I don't want to tell everybody we won
hooray you know stop fighting no no no
you got to be vigilant but you you pull
up a map of uh it used to be every state
was a basic basically a no issue or May
issue you wanted a gun you'd go to the
police you'd go to the government say
can I get a permit they'd say sure and
then they'd never give it to you now
overwhelming I think I think more than
half this country is is open carry
meaning you can if you're a resident you
could walk into a gun store you do a
federal background check they hand you
the gun you can you can walk out holding
it some states like West Virginia Texas
now I I don't know how many states are
constitutional carry but but a lot of
Texas is now yeah meaning you can walk
in as a resident you fill out your uh
your your National instant check system
your next background check and then they
could Jam you up for for a few days
three days into the max but typically
you'll be cleared within five or ten
minutes and then you can actually take
the weapon and conceal it on your person
and go walk around so those rights have
been expanding rapidly and I think it's
important people know that I I think
we're winning across the board and what
we're seeing with the expansion of
these extremist policies and the
targeting of the likes of insurer and
these lawyers is that they're losing
control 26 States our constitutional
carry that's what I thought but it's
crazy to think more than half the
country allows you to just buy and carry
a weapon even like I started I got my
concealed carry perm in like 2019 and
then I just renewed it like yesterday
but uh I don't need it anymore like
their their uh constitutional carry now
right Lexus and they say uh you know if
West Virginia for instance if you get
your your concealed carry permit you
don't even get the background check per
weapon anymore because the process by
which you get your concealed carry
permit is your background check and at
that point you're allowed to just freely
purchase weapons whereas if you don't
have it you have to get a background
check every single time you buy they're
making guns out of graphene now do you
see that oh wow level 22. super
lightweight apparently
yeah so if you take a look at this image
right to Kerry in 1986 and you can watch
the progression uh this is awesome look
at I mean this is amazing May issue
means they're not giving it to you no
issue States Texas would not give you a
a permit for carrying a weapon
to in 2000 look at all these states red
states that are saying you can't carry
this is crazy Lewis constitutional carry
is that right blue is shall issue
meaning that if you apply for a permit
they have to give you one unrestricted
is constitutional carry look at the
expansion of constitutional carry in
this country
here we go 2019 2020
2021. look at this crazy people saying
they don't like ESG
you could get a gun in these states yeah
all the yellow ones were May issue
meaning you'd apply and they wouldn't
give it to you if you were lucky Maybe
that's crazy Ultimate Defense dude you
arm your citizen you allow your citizens
to arm themselves it's the ultimate but
let's stay organized this is the
important thing to consider the
polarization is extremism that we're
seeing we are seeing a rise of
Communists of authoritarians and they
are getting increasingly desperate
despite the fact that we've been winning
across the board on the issue of gun
rights they have been gaining control in
institutions they have been subverting
our children our education system our
entertainment uh uh industry and now
they're in government and the likes of
the democratic party have weaponized the
doj to try and go after anyone that
opposes them but I think they're going
to lose
I think they're going to lose and this
this should say it right to everybody's
face look man they have their victories
the conflict is never without your
losses and your wins but I think I think
we're winning
and everything they're doing is panic
and fear
but if at any point we stop and sit back
and think it's over they they win it
they win it yeah we're in the middle of
a global revolution of Consciousness
like it is the New World Order is
forming we have no time to waste there's
no reason to stop to keep pushing we
need to change and create the world in
the image of the United States
Constitution in my opinion this is our
one option I uh I I have a problem with
the idea of us needing to do stuff for
the rest of the world that's a very
authoritarian and it's very uh neocon
and very stuff that we got ourselves
into a lot of trouble in Iraq and
Afghanistan and all other play whole
bunch of other places trying to do it is
not America's job to make the rest of
the world like America and that's part
of why like nationalism should not be a
dirty word like you shouldn't be like
jingoistic and be like I want to export
War for my country but you should be
like it's okay for there to be countries
with different laws and I don't think
that it's a good idea to just because we
believe that America has like the best
system we can believe that but that
doesn't mean that other people in other
countries would agree that's and I think
that's what happened in Iraq we went in
there and we're like we're going to
deliver democracy but the Iraqi people
the population that you're giving the
the this new government or new structure
to has to be willing to accept it and
want to do it if America Falls to an
authoritarian uh government it will be
because the American people have said we
accept this it'll be because Democrats
have said we're going to vote for the
government to have this kind of power I
want everyone to look at this map real
quick
this is the uh finalized map of the
country and uh your guns where it's
green you do not need a permit to carry
concealed
that's crazy so you just walk into a gun
shop and buy it on the off the shelf
you're a resident you still have to go
through a federal background check you
can then take the weapon after being
cleared
put it in your belt or your holster
cover it up and walk on out you don't
need a permit where it's blue you do
need a permit but no longer do we have
the May issue or no issue States it used
to be and this this uh ruling just
dropped what was what was the ruling um
it's just like a year ago or whatever
when they said when they when the
Supreme Court ruled you have to give a
permit to Kerry if you have a permit I
remember what happened but I don't
remember Maryland for instance in New
Jersey were considered no issue yeah uh
they call themselves uh May issue you
apply for a permit and they claim
everyone can get a gun
but then in Maryland and New Jersey and
and parts of California you'd say okay
I'd like to get a permit and say what do
you need it for and you'd have to give
them a reason they approve of and they
never approve hold on if you're rich
they approve yep rich people this issue
oh hands down rich people would and
celebrities would go in and say I need a
gun and say why and they would say I'm
worth millions of dollars and I'm I'm
concerned for my safety oh right away
sir right away and they that you get
your permit regular working-class person
says you know look I want to keep my
family safe they say how dare you come
in here get out of here and the cops
with a smile on their face will arrest
you if you're trying to defend yourself
under the under second amendment rights
it seems like the law legal system is
class Warfare at its finest any rich
person can buy their way out of jail I
don't think it's just being rich Trump
is Rich it's it's it's not just the
money it's who you are it's who you know
right connections right but money plays
a big role for example um in in regular
villain Chicago everybody knows this
it's like I don't know what the current
ticket is it used to be 50 bucks if you
parked illegally and you know what that
means it means if you want to park to go
to see a baseball game it's 50 bucks
street parking 50 bucks exactly because
it's so hard to find parking people
would park double park park in front of
fire hydrants and be like I don't care
I'll take the 50 ticket otherwise I'm
not getting parking the only problem
with that is if they're going to go
ahead and tell you if you're in a place
they don't tell you where so they're
they're all I almost never saw anybody
get towed because there's too many cars
illegally parked okay so yeah Civil
Disobedience there are some tow
companies that be like all right boys
let's start pulling them in because
we're about to make money but for the
most part everybody just it was normal
that everyone did it however one time
someone parked double parked in front of
my apartment where my friend's car was
and we ain't playing no games we needed
to use the car and so it's just like no
I don't care bologna Hotel
I wanted to finish off what we were
talking about Phil earlier a few minutes
ago that um spreading American exception
around Earth because I used to be kind
of ambivalent about it then the wars
over in the Middle East happen I'm like
no I'm done go back to isolation we do
not need to be involved head in the sand
forget about it focus on me and then
just went hey like the whole globe
just started to take the United States
over like culture War International
deceit using the internet twisting
people defects messing with your
politicians and like we do need to be
involved with auditing and editing the
world's police force and the world's
governance
um I don't want to do it by force of
military that obviously failed in the
Middle East I think that almost always
not always it doesn't always feel you
can conquer an 80 years later if you're
willing to face the attrition those will
be your people but it takes generations
for that to happen and we're not really
in a world with everything happening so
quick but World War II and into that
stuff but of colonization yeah because
the thing is once you when you
industrialize war and make it possible
to annihilate entire cities the idea of
of using force and War to conquer
territory kind of stops being acceptable
and that's part of the reason why
there's been oxy Wars and small Wars
since World War II but we've managed to
avoid a a global uh World War because
there are there has been the
the effort by the West to prevent other
countries from having nuclear weapons
which we talked about the other night
um you know to to prevent the the uh
what's the word they use anyways other
countries have been getting nuclear
weapons proliferation thank you um but
the point is uh they
I'm sorry I lost it go ahead well you're
saying that it's hard to conquer and and
amalgamate the population with Total War
tactics yeah it's too dangerous but so I
I don't I'm open to hearing what you
guys think about not I mean you do kind
of have to force the like I'm forcing
this conversation right now in a sense
it's not it's not warlike good ideas
don't require Force but for me to even
come up here and sit down and put a
camera on and like force myself to be in
this situation I could easily be playing
video games alone in my room in a studio
apartment in the middle of the city copy
what they see that they like and you
know what that's why the United States
was the United States and everywhere
else like when I lived in Venezuela
everything the United States did was
awesome and everybody wanted to be like
the United States maybe they didn't say
it out right I mean we talked about it a
whole lot in Venezuela it's like oh did
you buy that in the U.S it's special
because you got in the U.S like you know
people want to copy what is good and so
if we were that country that we were
supposed to be people would be copying
us unfortunately that's not us anymore
and that was back in the 90s when people
were like it's U.S I love it
because from the 50s all the way through
I mean blue jeans blue jeans there's
people say that the thing that took the
Soviet Union out was blue jeans but so
we were just
going our country was just as corrupt in
the 90s but people didn't know so they
still worshiped the United States and
were willing to take on its ideals you
know I lived in Venezuela and I was like
wow this is corrupt that country over
there America they're so great it's not
corrupt and then I get here and I'm like
oh boy it's almost wrong a justification
to hide our corruption from the world we
do corruption so well though
I mean and to be to be fair as far as
corruption goes the United States is
exceptional right in other countries are
really bad like they're they're
countries yeah there are countries where
if you get pulled over like you're not
getting a ticket you're handing him a
hundred bucks or you're going to jail
that's it there's one or the other and
that as well as alcohol though I wanna I
wanna jump to the story as we talk about
uh the love for America
from marca.com Trump supporters unveil
massive Trump or death Banner they say
flag at Yankees game take a look at this
image
1776 2024 Trump or death you know that
kind of freaks me out
it's like if Trump doesn't get elected
what are they saying are they saying
Give me liberty or give me death except
it's Trump instead of liberty no I don't
know that that's the slogan of Cuba
right there are they saying that if
Trump isn't elected it will be death
what is the slogan of Cuba
patri uh your country or death that's
that's the slogan that's a Cuban slogan
right there which is why that song went
virally uh like your country or death
that's the slogan what's like what's the
the wrecked literal translation it's
Patriot Patriot is your Homeland
Homeland homelander death wow yeah with
Thomas was it Thomas Henry Give me
liberty or give me death that's the
whole like give me exactly what I want
or I'll die no no no no no no that's not
what he's saying he's saying leave me
alone
or I will fight you oh that's what's
being implied well Liberty the freedom
to do what I want or I will fight for
that Liberty and that means I will fight
to the death for that as opposed to give
me X or die it's not okay
give me death yeah it's it's leave me
alone you have two choices either you're
going to give me my Liberty or you're
going to have to kill me but giving
Liberty is basically leave me alone it's
not give me Donald Trump yeah give me a
result it's each day off my lawn so
Liberty is a negative right so you don't
need to be given a thing or you don't
need someone else to act on your behalf
it's not a positive action to have
Liberty right so Give me liberty is
leave me alone like don't try to take a
positive action action against me but in
Cuba for it's like worship the Patriot
worship the Homeland or yeah that was
Fidel slogan that's what they came into
Cuba with was so
um yeah when I saw that flag I was like
whoa that's authoritarian AF yeah man uh
you mentioned the charismatic guy that
comes in and destroys the world destroys
I feel like Obama did it and then Trump
just kept going well we all thought
about Obama was going to be our savior
right I mean like that was the big thing
I didn't I'm sure nobody at this table
did but I think so I had I felt like
that yeah I mean a lot finally we got it
yeah and it was like you know he's this
great guy he looks good on camera man
the man can dress you know and he's he
says all the right things and then you
know drops a few bums on kids and
American citizens and you know it's it's
it's just
wow it's scary to watch it's scary to
watch and pay attention Obama is more
likely to be the charismatic like
if someone were to come to me and said
do you think that the charismatic leader
who leader who leads the world to
destruction is around today I'd be like
it's possible if you came to me and said
you thought it was either Trump or Obama
but oh there's no question it's not
Trump the dude certainly has Charisma
but he also has serious issues with half
the country and a lot of people really
don't like him he he's he's not
he's he's yeah they're forcing us to
like him is the famous silver silver
tongue you know world leader celebrity
who was doing awful well I don't know if
I'd say awful but Trump was like a movie
star he was a TV star like a character
actor with telling jokes you know you're
fired with a smile calling Rosie
O'Donnell fat like just a just a
charismatic even though he was sick but
you can be charismatic and cruel or
charismatic and say mean things that
upset people charismatically and that he
did that so my point is simply if it
came down to who do you think out of the
two was more likely to be the
charismatic leader who leads the world
to rone it's Obama I felt like it was a
package it was it was 2008 to 2020 we
had this mess of celebrity in charge
that just made it about who who can who
can smack talk better it got hotter the
longer it went on I I think that's
probably just a a an artifact of
this is your generation but it never
happened because yeah Ronald Reagan was
a movie star but he didn't act like that
he wasn't like he did I was literally
watching a documentary earlier it's
hilarious by the way and I forgot what
it's called but it's like how my dad got
radicalized from a Democrat to far right
because of Rush Limbaugh and it was
really hilarious watching this thing
because it's it's mirror reality I mean
they got the guy from Media Matters and
this and Media Matters just posts like
insane lies all the time in conspiracy
theories and I'm like to act like you're
not in the cult and you're listening to
this guy but uh in it they're talking
about Ronald Reagan they're talking
about Richard Nixon they're talking
about the fast quick one-liners and
demagoguery and celebrity and building
Cults of personality and I'm like oh
this is really fun yeah they did with
Clinton and this is the saxophone on
Arsenio Hall or something on TV man this
documentary is about Rush Limbaugh this
is about like you know the 2000 the 90s
and 2000s this is not about even Trump
they've been saying the same thing over
and over again they said Bush was Hitler
every Republican is Hitler it's the same
game they play every single time the
difference is social media because if
Reagan Reagan wasn't able to get his
word out without the networks going on
to like you know David Letterman or
something so that it was all Network
approved but Trump bypasses this the FCC
and goes straight to the mouth with like
Twitter and it just upended the entire
like any kind of normalcy or like things
you don't like you don't go on not
national television and call someone a
fat pig when you're the president use
that pulpit and that power and that
authority to demean someone's physical
appearance it's like what in the hell
did he just do to the essence of the
United States presidency that was a
terrible misuse of power in my opinion I
mean
I don't think that Obama was really
like I I don't think that that uh that
Trump was really significantly worse
than other presidents like they're
significantly better yeah well when it
comes to rhetoric and stuff like that
policy people act like the rhetoric that
he that he had like like was so bad and
I agree with you about foreign policy um
but the uh I don't think that he really
was he was a little more direct in the
way that he spoke
but he wasn't
and and maybe maybe other presidents
were
they were a little more they had a
little more finesse but the thing that
people liked about Trump was that he was
just saying it like it is right like he
was an authentic guy he was bsing people
but it was not it didn't seem like it
was canned or written by a speech writer
and that people related to that he's
honest where it matters yeah he's like
we're gonna keep soldiers in Syria for
the oil we got to keep the oil we're
doing really well it's like wow yeah you
just said we're gonna sell weapons to
Saudi Arabia and we're like okay all
right and then he would be like my hair
is real and I'm the best and everyone
loves me and you're like okay Trump it's
like he he lies a lot but the things he
lies about I don't care about it's like
people were at his inauguration yeah
exactly how many people were there oh
it's the biggest the biggest you've ever
seen is like we know it wasn't but it's
fine whatever dude look if Donald Trump
is sitting there and he's like
he's in his room saying oh there's a
million people here right now watching
watching me sign these peace agreements
in the Middle East I'm like that's right
they're all watching and waiting for you
to sign those peace agreements please
sign them like I don't care if Trump
wants to lie about the size of
inauguration or the women he's been with
and all this weird stupid nonsense
cultural crap
I care that we got the Abraham Accords I
care that the economy was doing well I
care that he took tremendous efforts to
try and bring peace to parts of the the
world like in North Korea
and they attack him for it and that one
deeply offends me and I love saying it
Trump crossed the military demilitarized
zone into enemy territory with no
security detail
yeah nah you can f off anybody who's
like Trump's pawning up dictators I'm
like oh okay yeah nice try dude that's
not gonna fly
they could have captured the President
right there on the spot and made demands
I mean they wouldn't Trump was right he
knew the move to be made but it was a
tremendous sign of good faith Trump can
tell me that his house is made of cheese
and graham crackers and sugar and candy
canes and he can look me Square in the
eyes and lie he can tell me that his
toilet is made of solid gold and I'll
say whatever you say dude keep working
on those peace agreements and I'm
satisfied
just be like are you sure it's solid
isn't it just you're right you're
absolutely right I think it's played
it's like Zoolander when Zoolander looks
at the the you know the what is the
institute for kids who can't read good
or whatever and he's like how are we
going to teach them to read if they
can't fit in the building and then
mugatu is like he's absolutely right
like that I'm saying if Trump wants me
wants me to believe that he had the
biggest inauguration or any other
nonsense like that and he keeps saying
it I'm just gonna be like yes you are
completely correct sir and that's all of
those people at your inauguration are
cheering for you as you sign the Abraham
Accords and try and bring peace to the
Middle East
I was thinking what happened the other
night like who was the best president of
my lifetime and it comes up a lot on the
show and I was like well in red there's
two ways to answer the question one is
with retrospect the other one is at that
point in my life who was it thinking of
like in this moment who's the best it
was Bill Clinton because in the late 90s
or in the early mid 90s he was able to
rally and like make the United States
seem like the greatest country on Earth
for all of us it felt like it felt like
that it felt like we ended the Cold War
and it was finally we've solved War it
felt like it was really done and then
you find out later they're part of a
military war machine and I don't know
what happened in Bosnia and like he
was Trump's the best president of my
life and and he's just so divisive
that's why I don't pick him I I disagree
I blame the corrupt uniparty
establishment Trump was a massive
celebrity loved by everybody Barack
Obama said the American dream was to
beat Trump but Trump was an outsider who
wanted to do things like bring back
manufacturing secure our borders and the
TPP I I gotta tell you when he crushed
the TPP that's probably one of the
biggest moments where the knives came
out and then they did everything in
their power to make everybody hate Trump
I'm like everybody loves the guy he was
in Home Alone
I'm gonna say it again Barack Obama said
the American dream is to be Donald Trump
that was the idea before he decided to
run for president and they came after
him and even the people who there are
certain celebrities who are like oh I've
been good friends of the Trump family
they're all very very nice but Trump's a
fascist and I'm like oh get get out of
here with that look
it is not it is not hard to say that
Trump is the greatest president of my
lifetime because who am I comparing him
to Bill Clinton no please Camp George
Bush was my least favorite George so we
so in my lifetime I've had H.W bush
Clinton W bush Obama and Trump
and certainly you can compliment some of
these presidents for some things but
come on H.W bush oh please dude
what do you say we're beginning to see
the makings of a new world order and all
of that neocon garbage and Desert Storm
and everything they tried to do you get
Bill Clinton and don't get me wrong
there are some good economic stuff but
uh there's a whole lot of stuff wrong
with what bill with with Bill Clinton's
presidency and I have to say for the
most part
when it comes to those two presidents in
my lifetime
it was it was it was it there was
nothing in my life that they did that
mattered and so the most I can say is
Bill Clinton's got all the scandals I
mean you know oh my God that was like
the stupidest Scandal of all oh no I'm
right I'm saying in terms of oh my God a
famous man who had sex outside of
marriage like wow I am shocked but in
terms of What mattered to me
H.W bush was bad with war
with with Clinton we certainly had a
great degree of conflict with George W
bush we got the worst of it in my
lifetime with Iraq and Afghanistan the
expansion of conflict in the Middle East
uh Barack Obama's extra judicial
assassinations of American citizens and
then we get Trump and for everything I
can't say about the Clinton years
because I was too little I can say no
new Wars Abraham Accords peace
agreements in in Europe
um getting people to commit to paying
their fair share with NATO working on
peace agreements with North Korea
securing our borders bringing back
manufacturing there's no question it's
just it really is an easy answer
man I don't I don't want to repeat
myself too much but the pr I believe the
pr one of the president's main jobs is
to unify the States you know preside
over the United States and keep them
United and if a president comes in and
tells half the country that they're
not part of the group or is that that uh
well maybe it's a Libertarian in me I
just I'm sorry I can't tell you which is
my favorite President because I don't
have one because all of them have done
some terrible things and I think they
should pretty much all be kind of
charged I mean there's there's yeah I
mean like now you know Clinton was on
Epstein's plane
yeah you know like so it's hard for me
sitting here because it's like yeah
Obama looked great when he was wearing
his suits and bombing people you know
across the world like it's just it's
really hard and also the United States
if you look at it that way where we need
some some leader would be the largest
corporation on the planet and I just
can't imagine that anybody who's running
for office even Donald Trump who's I'm
sure a great business person however
um I just can't Envision anybody being
able to actually manage a corporation
with 330 million people and trillions of
dollars so bureaucracy too yeah I mean I
listen I I love the United States I
think this country is an amazing place
and I think it we should go back to to
that freedom that allowed us to be that
amazing place I do not believe that
there is somebody in Washington writing
down you know some magic scroll that'll
somehow protect us or do something you
know we just need our freedom to get to
that point you mentioned like going back
to what was good but we're going to go
forward to a new envisioning of what was
good or what is good how would you like
Define we need a new vision for it but
we should go back to the Constitution I
mean I I just don't think that we need
this level of micromanagement and I
think with technology today we could
really achieve it without necessarily
having this I mean what does your local
government do and I I ran for a local a
seat in a local government government in
Miami-Dade County we have three million
people and a 10.3 billion dollar budget
that was billion with a B that is larger
than Nations that's larger than El
Salvador that has you know same amount
of people and a six billion dollar
budget what do those local people do
what exactly are they achieving for you
do we have transportation in Miami-Dade
County we do not nothing worthwhile I
mean it's terrible do they run anything
well no they don't and so what are you
getting for all of these taxes that
you're giving up what are we doing here
and I just I'm sorry I don't see it I
think that we really need to think this
through we've been giving up our
freedoms more and more and more each day
for what
I mean are you getting your money's
worth do you feel like I don't know I
don't know where the money's going to
the government it disappears into these
I can tell you on the local level
Miami-Dade County we pay for all sorts
of things that you would you would
probably just be
you know flabbergasted if you looked at
our budget like what oh okay so for
example I don't know what the budget is
right now for you know the homeless and
I think that's something that everybody
you know I want people to have a home I
want people to be well I don't want them
to be out on the streets and living
horrible lives so our budget is over 45
million dollars a year do the number of
homeless ever change no do we still have
homeless yes that's a cultural problem
absolutely and I don't think all that
with money we can't solve it with money
I think there's people that do not want
to live in this society and I don't
think you're gonna just throw money at
it and solve that problem so the number
of homeless we have I think generally is
around 3 000 and so when you divide the
amount of money we have you know by the
people that are unhoused
um you come up with some crazy number
you could afford apartments for these
people like what are we doing
administrators yeah but you can maintain
their jobs making money more homeless
aren't homeless because they can't
afford houses then why are we paying 45
million dollars out of Miami-Dade County
people who pay their taxes why do why is
somebody losing their home because
that's what happens if you can't afford
to pay your property taxes you will lose
your home the government will take away
your home and put it on the auction and
sell it that is one of the most
offensive things that I can think of one
like property taxes disgusting once you
own a piece of property you buy it you
shouldn't have to rent it from the
government like that is and it's obscene
amounts of money obscene amounts of
money and so you know you're paying this
money every single year you can't opt
out of it you can't say you know what
I'm not using any of your systems I
don't use public transportation you know
I'm not homeless like how can I how can
I opt out I can't so if I can't afford
to to maintain my house the government
will take it from me and
um so I'm paying for you know all these
services and it's just wrong so you
people will pay for homeless people
through taxes and then they if they
can't afford their own home they will
the government will take their home away
from them because they they spent their
health money on other people's
homelessness that's why I decided to run
in the first place I lived in my
grandfather's house when I couldn't
afford you know when I had a child at 21
and I couldn't afford to live you know
like and I moved in with my grandfather
and he was like Hey can you take care of
the bills and you know you can live here
for for free and I realized property
taxes my grandfather couldn't pay for it
he would have been out on the street and
that's generally who is affected the
most it's the elderly it is people who
have some type of disability it is
somebody who's going through hard times
medical you know medical difficulties
they lose their homes because they
couldn't pay for all the wish list that
the government those people who you
elect you know that sit there and are
just like you know they don't take
public transportation they don't they
they have security provided by
government provided by the police they
have all these things and they make
these decisions for you and if you don't
comply you will lose your home Michael
Schellenberg one potential solution
would be to uh we could install lights
in the palms of everyone's hands and as
they get closer to turning 30 the light
begins to turn red and and then when
they turn 30 it flashes red where we
then take them and excise them from
society why wow that's how we can handle
uh in the future of course we may have
to deal with people who try to flee and
don't want to undergo what was it called
I got the darkest it's Logan's Run it's
from the movie Logan's Run they called
it something though like I forgot what
it's called I don't remember yeah like
when you turn 30 they called it
something like the light on your hand
flashes and then you like they kill you
I think it's well if that was the case
I'm sorry guys bye I mean everybody in
this room I feel the right the oh I'm
well I'm well over 30.
um the homelessness crisis the
homelessness crisis is insane the way
that it's been handled and talked about
is very insane um Michael schellenberger
works out of California and he he really
exposed Carousel is that what it was
Carousel yeah they called it Carousel I
think it was shellenberger that exposed
the basically the the homelessness in
the homeless industry the industrial
complex it's an industry absolutely and
they they receive money every year to
fix it but instead of actually getting
homeless people homes they just pay the
administrators the bureaucracy to
maintain the status quo you still of the
same people are still homeless and they
keep making everything the kicker to so
I'm sorry I'm talking about Miami-Dade
it's what I know so pardon me you know
but um in Miami-Dade County the person
who runs the homeless trust which is who
has all this money is Ron book who is
the largest
um what would this be lobbyist for
government so I mean that's I guess his
reward is he gets to run this thing and
you know he's been doing it for I want
to say about 20 years you said that
there's the same amount of homeless
people every year are they new people
like are the people getting off the
street and the new people are arriving
or is it just tough to tell tough to you
look at a number it's 3 000 but I mean
everybody so where I live there's not a
whole lot of homeless because they
generally live in downtown where you
know they have more access to bathrooms
and whatnot
um so it's hard to tell but we generally
you kind of know who you know the
homeless guy is everybody knows the guy
on the corner like you know and he's
always there and they come around and
they sweep every now and then and remove
them and you know throw out all his
stuff his few possessions and it's so
sad it's it's the saddest thing honestly
hit him with fire hoses in the morning
no not in Miami San Francisco no we're
not that cruel we're not there yet you
know give it a few 4 a.m they just come
in and there's video of it it's Tiff
it's I got awful honestly were you gonna
say something Phil looks like you're
about to jump on an idea
I do want to talk about this story
though ladies and gentlemen it's not
going to be Donald Trump
nor will it be Joe Biden the man who
will save this world
is Elon Musk
I'm being facetious that's kind of the
joke but I'm I'm also only half joking
aside from Elon challenging The
Narrative machine of the ADL calling out
corrupt politicians securing not
perfectly but helping people bring back
free expression on social media Elon
Musk it has been reported now averted
World War III and may have saved the
planet from nuclear annihilation
the probability of that being the
circumstance is probably very very low
but it just sounds fun so I want to say
it the story is actually really simple
we have this from The Washington Post
Elon Musk cut internet to Ukraine's
military as it was attacking Russian
Fleet
so the first story that comes out is
that while this major counter-offensive
was underway Elon Musk shuts down
starlink cutting their Communications
stopping the offensive
Elon Musk responded saying there was an
emergency request from government
authorities to activate starlink all the
way to Sebastopol the obvious intent
being to sink most of the Russian Fleet
at anchor if I had agreed to their
request then SpaceX would be explicitly
complicit in a major Act of war and
conflict escalation
I wonder if uh wrong article if Ukraine
sank Russia's Black Sea Fleet using
SpaceX using U.S weapons and
intelligence would Russia have
dramatically escalated the conflict at
the time there is a possibility it may
have been the case I don't know for sure
but Elon Musk refused to provide
starlink to be used by the ukrainians in
this counter-offensive do you know may
have single-handedly stopped a major
escalation which could have led to World
War III do you know what uh the size of
the fleet was in the makeup of the fleet
and sevastopol at the time no we do know
that
um U.S provided intelligence to Ukraine
to sink their flagship
yep Ukraine used U.S weapons and
intelligence
and I I think it's even unfair to say
the U.S sank the flagship of Russia's
Black Sea Fleet and and Ukraine was
intending to do more damage and Elon
Musk said I'm not going to assist you
with this
could you imagine if he did
that's crazy
he was pretty open in the early days
that he didn't want to be involved with
the war and I think he was gonna give
them he was gonna send Starling to
Ukraine and then they they said no
because they wouldn't do it under his
terms or something and then he was like
okay then and they're like actually we
need it
so then he and then he sent it over
there it was a long time ago
yeah he's trying to protect Earth until
we can get off of it and go to Mars you
know The Men Who Built America were not
politicians they were businessmen yeah
but but I'm curious I mean
in terms of the unit party establishment
machine
man Elon Musk is running a foul but it
shows the the decay of the uniparti
power in that Elon Musk openly defies
them does not allow them to wage war
using his infrastructure this is
unprecedented if you look at Twitter
before Elon they gleefully gave the
government anything they wanted
it kind of I'm I'm I'm optimistic man
he's making me into a bigger fan so but
I'm just I'm a CIA I'm looking at a
restoration of true American values of
decentralization of power and for the
longest time we had an authoritarian
uniparty that did whatever it wanted
regardless of the Constitution now you
look at all of their devices you look at
the activist base you look at the
narrative machine and they're failing
across the board
people tweeting about how the ADL no
longer has any power they say oh all
these people who are criticized because
our white supremacists and everyone
laughs no one cares anymore they they're
they're they're they have been defanged
it's kind of like the uniparty when two
unit parties go at it it creates an
opportunity for a revolution that's what
happened with two unit parties yeah you
don't need a revolution revolution's a
bad word what happened with the American
founding fathers is that there was a
uniparty of of the Brits and there was
the uniparty of the oh that is
completely they went at each other and
the result was a Liberation they were
they were totally different countries
though yeah and they were like two
separate like they were Monarch they
were Monarch they were literal
uniparties and now we have the American
uniparty of the liberal economic order
and the Chinese ruse liberal like or not
liberal but yeah and they're clashing in
Ukraine so now there's an opportunity
for like businessmen to step in and
create something new I I see what you
what you are saying like the author the
unilateral rule of the of the United
States clashing with other
authoritarians but Russia may be aligned
with China and bricks and everything but
when you get to the global scale it's
not una party there's greater conflict
between nations I suppose the ccp's unit
party and a party refers to in the
United States the Democrats and
Republicans that are secretly aligned
and pretend to be opposed yeah well the
Chinese Communist party is literally a
una party that runs that country but the
United States and China are not aligned
so it's not a global uni party it's no
no it's two unit parties going at each
other so that's why I think it's an
opportunity for for the private sector
to be like well you guys quibble we're
gonna create something functional
and you see Elon doing it in real time
maybe we should call in the United
States the former unit party because
they've lost too much power at this
point
you know look I know that they're
arresting and charging people and all
that stuff but they're really failing at
it every step of the way their their
ability to influence is weakening
drastically uh midi Hassan uh interview
um Vivek ramaswamy and there's lag it's
MSNBC 2023 and they still have lag in
their video conference well it's always
been like yo brilliant it has like I use
zoom there's no lag I use Skype there's
no lag what the hell infrastructure is
this archaic dinosaur of a media
monolith using that there's still
freaking lag and they can't have
sometimes they can't even figure out
stereo and mono like you guys are in one
ear and like do you guys remember when
CNN did the satellite interview from the
same parking lot
yeah two people in the same parking lot
and they did a satellite interview as if
there were different places so the
reason I brought up lag in MSNBC is
because I think that's just evidence of
what you're saying that the uni party
function is crumbled they're just so
behind the times oh the ratings are in
the gutter their influence is down is is
almost gone uh the fact that Elon bought
Twitter and turned it into X is a huge
example of this they were using Twitter
as a weapon to spy on people to control
and to influence I know they've lost it
it's remarkable how much they keep
losing which is why they're getting
desperate and trying to remove Trump
from the ballot and have him and have
him arrested because they know they're
losing I'd like for the American
government to win I don't know if
there's just one government I'd like for
them I'd like people to win me too yeah
I'm on that team you know what I will
say that they're that we're winning the
American people are winning when Assange
is freed when we have Edward Snowden
back in the U.S without fear of him
going to jail for a long time when
people like Ross all break their free
like I I I I hear what you're saying and
I want to believe it but we're not there
quite yet we just sent a man to we just
sentenced the man to 22 years in prison
to Enrique tario which I don't agree
with him you know necessarily but
what did he do he wasn't even in the
Capitol Building like what are we doing
here agreement is entirely irrelevant
I'm not trying to like to even discuss
whether or not you agree
actually blunts the point it doesn't
matter it does not matter however
internet people will then be like oh my
God you're a fan I mean I I was already
called you know in during my campaign I
took a picture with somebody and they
were like terrible in their contempt
welcome they're contempt I I work for it
absolutely but I'm just saying I don't
support the proud boys however you know
what they've done to this guy is
horrible absolutely horrible and if they
can do it to him they can do it to you
and that's the problem if they're going
to come after people it's going to be
People Like Us in this room it's going
to be people who are speaking out and
saying things and if they can put
Enrique Taria who three I don't know
five years ago I don't even know who the
guy was and all of a sudden he's he
deserves 22 years in prison
he texted people to go do something if I
text you to go do something are you
gonna do it the defense said that he
wasn't in contact with anyone that day
and apparently the prosecution and the
media is reporting that he said don't
leave but we I don't know the context to
what she said don't leave was it the day
before they were like Hey we're in DC
which we know is like well don't leave
and now they're making it seem like he
was saying stay in the capital the
defense that he didn't contact them at
any point uh I will say
if it comes to the point where they
begin going beyond the scope of you know
oh and Shroyer who is on the ground and
they're saying his speech warrants a
prison sentence
he was on the ground and that's their
pretext for the arrest if they escalate
to the point where they're coming after
pundits I would argue that out of anyone
in this room Ian's the first person they
target
man you know why it's like a long hair
bro and I'm a wizard this happened with
uh when I was with lucrutkowski in
Chicago and the police planted we
believe they planted drugs in the
apartment we're staying at
they target people who are less likely
to be able to muster up legal defense
funds so if they wanted to disrupt a
show like this and make claims about
rhetoric or inflammatory things uh would
they go after me well that's probably a
bad idea it would create a huge PR press
storm it would create a huge backlash we
generate tons of money and it would
create a huge legal fight would they go
after Phil Labonte multi-platinum
recording artist I mean that could
create a huge wave across the
entertainment industry Ian on the other
hand you are you have the the you are
the least like that of anyone here to be
able to muster up a strong legal defense
granted we would defend you what I'm
saying is I don't think anyone's gonna
come and try and arrest you I'm saying
the target of who they go after is who
can we get easily Enrique atario the
proud boys most people don't know who he
is they're not gonna look yeah they
they're they're they're waiting to go
after Trump until they can build
everything up on the ground because they
know a direct move against Trump is it
makes it millions of dollars it
strengthens them
I've never been a trump supporter and
all of a sudden I'm like you know what
I'm going for the political prisoner
like that's it so who else right so
Vivek ramaswamy yes but I do like Vivek
also however is he gonna be the nominee
you look at January 6 and they go after
people you've never heard of that don't
make the press and you don't even know
are in jail and these people try as they
might can't get the word out there's too
many of them this is what they do one at
a time
then they announce two and a half years
later that Owen Shroyer will be
criminally charged they're they're
they're starting from the bottom and
moving upwards it's very much like um
that story we talk about eBay you know
when eBay was started it was yellow and
they wanted to change the background to
white but everyone got mad so they did
it one step at a time over the course of
a year they don't want to come out
immediately right after January 6 and
say Donald Trump you're under arrest it
would create chaos they got to go for
the easier low-hanging fruit which is
lower income people who are confused and
then what do they do they go to this you
know 37 year old woman who was walking
around the capitol waving a flag when
everyone in the building and they say
you're gonna go to prison for eight
years for for a felony charge for
terrorism
or you're going to write a letter saying
Trump made you do it
and then we're gonna say you can go home
right now time served and they they've
all how many people have taken this deal
how is it that any different to our
regular justice system well no but this
is my point my point is
they if they go head-to-head with Trump
trump rallies his base sure if they
weaken his Base by getting his
supporters to write letters saying Trump
did this and ordered me to do it and
then used it for propaganda knowing
these people no one will ever hear their
names
they won't raise money it's also laid
that base now that you've heard that all
these people have been charged if you're
a layperson you know you go to work
every day you got the kids you got stuff
going on you're not really paying
attention you have no idea what these
people have been charged with you here I
don't know how many people have been
arrested now all of a sudden it's like
an actual thing it's like well all those
people are arrested of course they had
to have done something terrible so it
adds to that level of yeah they did
something of course you got to go for
Trump because he's the orchestrator of
all these people they get enough people
to sign letters saying Trump ordered me
to do it then they say we have sworn
witness testimony from 372 people saying
Trump instructed them to do it under
duress of course but is that not
mattered in the argument that it's it's
it's part of the strategy so ultimately
my point is if they start going after
personalities oh and Shroyer I think
proves this point one they have a
pretext he was on the capitol grounds
shouldn't have done it you go to prison
for three months that's ridiculous but
they're using his speech the speech is
opening the door to targeting other
personalities who are online the next
person will likely see charge is going
to be someone who maybe has a hundred
two hundred thousand followers of
subscribers and they're gonna say they
advocated for incited and instructed
people to commit a crime I'm gonna tell
you right now there were people on
Twitter on YouTube and other social
platforms before January 6 who posted
videos advocating for people to engage
in direct conflict
and really like violent conflict
and there's no question about it
I think these people some of whom have
instantly flipped and become total to
Santa supporters
probably flipped because they know uh oh
they're they're next in line
after the j-sections were on the ground
they're going to come out and say you
committed an act of sedition by making
these videos advocating for Insurrection
against the United States government you
know it's worth noting too like for the
entire time that antifa was rioting and
stuff they were they had signs that said
that they wanted Revolution that they
wanted to tear down the government they
want you know that no uh no what is it
no no wall no border no USA at all or
whatever it was they literally want to
see the United States be you know
dissolved and stuff like that and it was
completely acceptable they did this
stuff while they were firebombing a
government building they were they they
were saying these kind of things while
they were attacking the the White House
on whatever that was it May 29th or
something like that was the uh the when
they had to move Trump to The Bungalow
under the uh under the White House but
either way the point is these these kind
of threats and stuff like that these
things have have been going on for a
long time and it's not new the only
reason that they're going after the
people that were at January 6th is
because they have the wrong politics
they are the wrong people it's
acceptable to be anti-government if
you're anti-government for the left
there are people that have bombed
Congress that Bill Clinton pardoned you
know like I forget the woman's name she
was a communist yep um but they
literally set off a bomb in Democrat
Capital the Democrat in Georgia will not
be involved in the criminal the the D.A
will not be involved in the criminal
prosecution of the antifa terrorists who
were firebombing the the police HQ
burning down homes building vehicles and
shooting at cops the Democrats are
bowing out and saying we won't we won't
charge them they're literally saying
that you don't matter that what matters
here is that institution I mean if
government is more important than the
people then that's a statement
I think they're outright saying that if
you do these things we're on your side
yeah because I mean I know that there's
people that don't believe it but there
are actual Communists in Congress people
that are the squad or all DSA members or
at least they they caucus with the DSA
they caucus with Communists I there
there is no significant light between
AOC
and any of the any of the DSA members
that are actual members of the DSA
there's no significant difference in
their policy decisions or what they what
they're looking for I don't know enough
about the differentials but socialists
are different than Communists I would
imagine that they didn't want State
control the goal of socialism is
communism Vladimir Lenin the goal of
social you know you know what communism
is like you guys ever see From Dusk Till
Dawn like yes yeah yeah you know when um
uh it's Cheech I think he's outside and
he's talking about all the beautiful
women that are inside and all the
different kinds of women's parts that
are available and then they're like we
gotta go inside there but then they walk
in it's a bunch of vampires who are
trying to kill them that's communism
outside they're like dude if you come in
here we got Peach so we got video games
we got fast cars everybody gets to have
anything you want what do you want
anyone open source code we gotta open
five open source codes we got five open
source codes Phil we got a big stage for
you to play you're gonna get everything
you've ever wanted you walk in the door
they lock it behind you and then they go
and now we're gonna kill you know what I
don't believe Vladimir Lenin when he
said that that socialism's the road to
Communism I feel like he twisted
socialism for his own game kind of like
saying liberalism is the road to Fascism
he did not he did not he meant it that's
what he thought he used it he believed
it he killed a bunch of people
it was history
you know family history here and uh
personal history
um they never promise you communism when
you look at Cuba you look at Venezuela
and there there was never a point where
they're like you know what I am a
communist they always go for the no it's
just a little bit of socialism
everything's gonna be great we're all
gonna share everything's gonna be
fantastic you want Healthcare I got your
health care you want this you want a
home I've got you they promised this
this land it's exactly like Tim just
said it is that promise so I guess
socialized Services is different than
socialism so yes and we should debate
what systems should be socialized so
there's there's there's things that
conservatives argue so that way or in in
in order to prevent a you know a policy
or whatever but a lot of the social
services that we myself as you know
personally I'm kind of against the stuff
but they were made with the intent to
defuse the desire for the United States
to become a more socialist country so in
the Progressive Era like the first half
of the 20th century uh Fascism and
socialism were all the rage right State
the state was in charge the government
could do things and we because we were
now industrial countries and stuff we
could you know the state itself can do
all kinds of massive projects et cetera
et cetera and everybody was buying it
um
so the the the I don't know why I just
slipped out of my head we were talking
about what we were saying before
communism communism yeah but the point
is like you say they're using socialist
tactics to diffuse the desire for
socialism yeah because the the world
kind of was on fire for fascism and
communism because and socialism because
before the end of World War II fascism
didn't have the same kind of uh dirty
dirty connotations that it does neither
did Communism to be fair
um and these were new ideas they were
innovations that people were all excited
about because we could you know we could
we could remake man and remake the world
because we had all this power because
and and the thing is all those policies
actually there's an argument that those
policies actually prevented the United
States from falling into an actual
socialist uh situation because the the
government stepped in said well we'll
use social programs but we're gonna keep
you know the things that are that keep
us free so I'm not sure if I think it
was you know the best option but that is
is an argument that you guys uh you guys
know there's a statue of Lenin in
Seattle whoa whoa they did not know
still standing makes sense they'll pull
down Hans Christian Hague who fought to
end slavery they'll tear down the
founding fathers but uh not him the
problem with Lenin is he looked so cool
dude
just a shadow goatee just angular it's
kind of like the problem with socialism
in general yeah it looks great like
Lennon is so what a unique looking dude
they've modeled video game character I
mean I think that the reason I think he
looks cool is because I've seen video
characters teen foot tall statue of a
Lennon in Seattle what a guy 15 foot
yeah they even had to exaggerate that
I lived in Fremont briefly
I don't even know if we should know we
would see that one no he can't no we
shouldn't we definitely shouldn't Lennon
is like Marxism leninism is the idea
that has like led to all sorts of
killing so Lenin's perspective was
socialism London was like Marx is wrong
socialism will not just happen right if
the idea was you had feudalism then you
had capitalism and then once capitalism
made enough product and stuff then you
would have socialism and it would just
happen right and then after social once
you had socialism then the people would
start realizing that socialism works and
then that the government itself is
redundant because people are doing the
things that need to be done not the
government and then no was that sorry
yep apparently it's for sale
and the statue I'll get it and uh in
1996 they wanted 150 000 for it right
which of the equivalent today would be
280 000 for it what say uh we buy it and
then destroy it I so badly want to do
this I love this I want to leave it I
mean it's a historical artifact just
stick it somewhere that is a fair point
I'm not buying I'll pee on it
I'm into that you need to do more than
just people you know what I would love
to paint it make it look like him in
real life or something put like a clown
face on it that'd be crazy oh my God you
should do different wigs and stuff on
them buy it and half bury it at Freedom
oh it's just head sticking out but
charge people money to defile it you can
walk by and smack it with a with a shoe
chicken eggs at it we could put it in a
shooting range and you could pay money
dude you should hold on to it like any
good statue do you think they'd sell it
to me if I told them like my intention
is to bring it to a shooting range we
should stop talking about this right now
after show only we just want to repaint
it like the Statue of Liberty I got a
question for you guys about the
president do you think because I was
thinking last night
oh man a lot of the people that watch
this show enjoy Donald Trump so I don't
want to be too much of a dig on him but
last time I was like I feel like voting
for Trump right now is like the Lazy
Man's vote it's just like go in there
and just do it I don't even know but
like Vivek is the intellectual it's the
challenging route because he actually
has a plan you have to think about it
and actually learn things to understand
how to manipulate our government program
fake was talking about the uh stuff with
uh Infowars and stuff like that so
another another
good thing about the Vegas he's talking
about these you know these kind of
things that other politicians don't seem
to to be talking sorry super complicated
stuff too like it takes hours to listen
to it and then you might have a piece of
it but like that's the challenge I want
to throw out there that Vivek also said
that he would pardon Ross day one
Ross Albrecht Russell bricked Silk Road
um you know and I think that that is for
me that's that's a number one reason to
vote for him I I do like what he's doing
I do like that he's going to these shows
and and being real which politician in
America is real you know and I think
Vivek is he's he's coming to all these
shows and and you know doing the work
um it's really easy to get a quick sound
bite and just you know something that
your manager gave you and like blah blah
blah I think everybody should have this
and then he's actually there explaining
things he's also talking about cutting
you know lots of government agencies and
I love that part yeah huh should we
should we launch a give send to go
for the purpose of purchasing the Lenin
statue recover for recovering the statue
we must recover it from the capitalist
oppressors that have colonized his
likeness they're selling it for money is
really hilarious by the way it's live we
made it and we're going to sell it to
you for a lot of money I mean six
figures this is no joke you could buy a
house for that money
that's a lot of money for a big pile of
but I'm I got to tell you rock I hear me
out I'm fairly confident that if I
bought this
and then brought it to a big piece of
rural land and said for five dollars you
can defile it in any way you want take
my money oh I'd make so much money take
my money all of it just let me let me
please
for me and this one's for my dad yeah
there would be Floridian pilgrimages of
people being like why don't we just put
it in Florida let's put in the capital
Latin America Miami and let's just you
know let the people that have had to
flee their countries in recent times
take care of it for you I I like it take
care of it if it was about care of it if
it was the bald statue of Lenin I'd be
into it but he's got a hat on a lot of
respect for ball guys we don't get rid
of that hat there's um what is the
nonprofit the victims of uh communism
victims of Communism it would be cool to
like buy it and donate it to them and
say like do with it what you will I love
this make it special I think you should
definitely do it gives and go and see if
people will donate to do it get people
to you know if I were to do a gift set
and go it would be like there it would
have to be to give it to the victims of
Communism Memorial or whatever so I
would I like in fact I would reach out
to a how about to use it to stop current
communism or at least educate people on
the current communism because communism
isn't over but when I've got an island
90 miles from our Shores that is
full-on communist it's adapting to to
the monetary what I'm saying is Chinese
communism isn't real
communism is real communism what I'm
saying is I would not crowdfund to buy
this to personally own if we do a
crowdfund it's so that an anti-communist
organization can can get ownership of it
like I'm saying like I don't like the
idea we do a gifts and go everyone gives
money which effectively gives me I don't
want the statue like if I was gonna buy
the statue on my own I'd buy it on my
own and I charge admission for people to
file it that's hilarious turning him
into a capitalist spectacle for
capitalists to make money off of is just
oh it's icing on the cake I love it so
it's a possibility
um the first question is will they will
they actually sell it to someone they
know is going to defile it
uh but I think they legitimately would
sell it to the victims of Communism or
some non-profit but it's also a question
too would would like a non-profit like
the victims of Communism want to be
involved in something so crude would
that be besmirching the memory of those
who are who are killed by these monsters
no this was created in the in
Czechoslovakia during the the Soviet
Union's reign in 88 1988 and then after
uh the dissolution of the USSR
was brought to America in 1993 so I
don't think this is has anything with
people that loved communism this is
people that fled the Soviet Union
uh it was made by a bulgarian-born
Slovak sculptor named Emil venkov I
don't know what his communist ties were
I'm just you know it would be hilarious
to see what antifa would do if we're
like guitars now to be very confused
uh it's made of bronze maybe we could
polish it I think I have to buy it dude
what am I alive for if not to buy the
statue of Lenin I love that so that you
do so that we can topple it have Phil
Labonte stand on top of it
he's got like a thing behind him you can
sit on maybe you can set up a drum kit
or something I really I'm gonna pursue
this because you just think like I'm I
look at the great works I I look at the
the
you know I play Civilization right and
in Civilization every so often you get
great figures so it's like you'll get a
little dude it'll be called like
musician and then you can place him
somewhere and he makes culture but every
so often you'll get like it it you'll
like Beethoven appears and he's a guy
you can go and then create a great work
and the great work creates cultural
influence and I think about where are we
today where's all of the significant
significant cultural stuff that matters
to people of this generation
I saw a meme and it's a it's a bunch of
cassette tapes and it said all of these
uh albums came out within like four
months of each other yeah everything
awesome right use your illusion one and
two Pearl Jam Nirvana uh never mind it's
like some type of Pilots bad mode bad
motor finger sound garden all yeah
sounds like a good year dude it's crazy
and so I'm thinking today
what what have we done this year what
has anyone done where it's like we're
gonna remember that crazy thing Oliver
Anthony I'll say for sure I'm not saying
nothing's been done I'm just saying like
think about the things that we we should
create to create that memory and that
cultural uh Waypoint as it were so I
kind of feel like you know Phil Labonte
standing on the the ruin of a shattered
Lenin statue singing in mockery of
Communism sure is one of those things to
be done light it from underneath that's
gonna look why oh yeah put some lights
underneath the thing it's like free with
like a ladder on the back or steps on
the back so you can climb up onto it
really easy Tim cast anti-coming you
know like I I don't like the destruction
of statues Confederate otherwise and
part like
the burning of the Library of Alexandria
is is a horror story to me like you know
if if someone's like you want to hear a
horror story you tell me about ghosts
and demons I'm like oh that's cool but
you tell me about the burning of the
Library of Alexandria and I'm like and
I'm like I'm hiding like no the
knowledge so you know destroying the
statue for no reason just like toppling
it is stupid
but doing something cultural artistic
with it is important you know one things
I Like About That civilization reference
you're talking about great people when
you're your Society produces a great
person Beethoven Steve Jobs whoever when
you get multiple great people all
produced at the same time in history
they can come together to create a
golden age and that's what's happened
with the internet
we're in a golden age we're in a time of
immense crisis but we're in a golden age
while we're Suffering The Crisis so it's
that much easier
we've got to use it while we have it
because it's every age comes to an end
maybe we write a song
and then we can use it in the music
video
like I'm thinking like can you create an
artistic work that represents
you know we we we deride and explain how
bad communism is and there's there's a
message that I think people often say
that doesn't get enough attention it
doesn't permeate enough and it's that
the Communists were infinitely worse or
I shouldn't say infinitely were
substantially worse in many ways than
the Nazis the Nazis committed probably
one of the most like evil atrocities but
the Communists had this long drawn out
70 years or longer 100 years even still
to this day with what China has done to
the uyghur Muslims it's just this
endless history of hundreds of millions
of dead the holiday more happened before
the Holocaust right and these things are
horrifying and Evil
so so at least saying like guys we get
it we we hate Nazis but can we also add
communism into I don't understand how we
don't have comedy I mean how I don't
know depending on whatever number you
want to use for how many how many people
perished under Nazism but communism that
number is so much more uh maybe 200
million people I mean it's just so big
oh oh my God Dylan butter says buy the
statue put a chicken bridge over it yeah
and play Lennon getting crapped on live
that's a really good idea I love it just
him like half out of the ground
City would be the best thing ever poor
chickens just having to deal with this
thing no the chickens would that we
would put the perch on it yeah where
they sleep and they just crap in their
sleep and it plops right onto Lenin
love it oh perfect I'll take I'll take a
look at it to be completely honest I
mean it's not like I just have 300 Grand
to buy a statue of Lenin with because
you can ship it too it's right massive
and shipping that's going to be Hefty
how much is this that's going to be a
serious cost to ship you get a get a
bunch of people that do a road trip go
pick it up that's why that's why I'm
like I really do think we could muster
up a crowdfund between it's not just
about like what this show can do but if
I reach out to a bunch of other
personnel and said guys let's promote
this and get a non-profit to buy the
statue and then do something critical of
Communism with it we'd raise that money
overnight
I agree and I love that idea I think
that there is communism still today and
a lot of people just don't know don't
know what it is don't know how miserable
it is don't understand the crisis
um again going back to Miami over a
million people who have fled communist
regimes live in Miami today and so
um yeah if you you got to live it or
talk to people who've lived it or do
some something like this buy a statue
and make sure people know what's going
on is the reason it fails and just
always has failed is because it sounds
great everyone's going to get enough and
then he gets to the point where you have
so many people we don't have enough
resources now everyone can't have enough
it fails because human beings are not
geared to be socialists well in small
groups we are like in a family unit but
that's your desire to give to your
children to give to your wife to give to
the people that you love now what desire
do you have if I tell you hey
I really need some money and I just I
want it because I want it what drives
you to go make that money for me if you
were my neighbor and you were like I
want some money because I'm gonna plant
some corn I could see like but Ian
you're talking about the when when so
you're talking about a concept that is a
has to be a at least National right so
you're talking about millions of people
and things work differently at different
resolutions right so so the way that the
way that uh um like
family works there's only four or five
you know that six whatever ten in your
immediate family communism is fine for
that you know because
the people that you're supporting need
you to take care of them children can't
go out and support themselves and take
themselves that works but once you get
to like your neighborhood you can't have
a communist neighborhood you can might
have some kind of you can have social
programs or social get-togethers and and
your neighbors can help each other but
it can't be just like Hey Joe makes a
hundred grand and Bill makes 30. so
we're gonna take you know Joe's money
and give some of it's a bill and stuff
and that's the way that it ends up
working out that ends up creating
animosity it ends up making mistrust it
ends up making people not feel like
working there's this idea called The
Tragedy of the commons right so if no
one owns something no one takes care of
it because they don't feel like they're
responsible for it that's one of the
things that property does right if you
own something then you feel like it is a
part of you on some level and it gives
you the desire to take care of it to
make it better to to build on it if you
don't have to take care of it what
happens everybody pisses on the seat
because you don't have to clean the
toilet public toilet they're always a
mess because no one takes care of them
like I was thinking then does it break
down in a little Society because
communism doesn't work after 60 people
or something because there's someone in
charge work after one right and there's
always somebody in charge because like
when you remove the incentive to do
anything because everyone's getting the
same thing then it becomes about forcing
people to do something and then
people are appointed to force other
people to do stuff and then before long
it just like well just think about it if
you like what get what incentivizes you
to do things right and it there has to
be something otherwise why leave your
house why you have to leave your house
and make money because otherwise the
electricity is going to be turned off
you you know you're not going to be able
to afford things you're not going to be
able to afford food so you go out you
you do your job and you come home with
your money and you pay for things if
everything was guaranteed to you light
electricity everything you know you just
you had it what's going to incentivize
you to leave
and go be productive and go make things
and go be part of this Society you know
it's kind of like what happened in covet
and and I think to this day a lot of
people have been talking about like
there's some
something shifted in our in our culture
a little bit where people just maybe
don't necessarily want to do a job you
know
um because you were incentivized to stay
home and and it kind of it's awesome I
mean great you get to stay home and live
your life and somebody else is going to
provide for you and it just doesn't work
things don't just magically appear that
food at the supermarket doesn't
magically just go up it's not like
somebody in the back of of your
Supermarket of your local supermarket is
just like you know these things
magically come out of them you have to
grow that food you have to produce that
food who's going to do that do you
really think people want to go work the
fields because they love it
yeah it sounds like what would it be
profit motive basically is what gets
people to do yes you need a profit and
also profit is the perfect regular like
way to regulate the market you know
exactly what somebody's willing to pay
for something you're willing to pay a
thousand dollars for a cell phone
because you find Value in that cell
phone right but if you know I was like
hey this apple phone whatever isn't
twenty thousand dollars maybe like yeah
I don't really need that there's a price
point that is the right point that
you're willing to pay for so that you
need that and do you think that you need
to let people I think I'll just tell you
this I think you need to let people
suffer and the ones that pick themselves
up and strive for something better are
the success ones that prep send their
genetics On to the Next Generation and
the ones that that can't get out of the
suffering die off and their genetics no
longer with us you ever you ever look at
the the
um Instagram page uh like what is it uh
nature is metal
so one of the things that that page
constantly says right and shows you all
kinds of stuff animals get eaten all the
time and he's like look Nature's not
fair
it's brutal and and the cheater is and
the most brutal are rewarded and so what
you need to do is you need to have your
Society
be in harmony with the fact that the
world is unfair and I'm not saying
except that it's unfair and just be like
oh well this is the way it is and just
ignore it but when I say be in harmony
means you have to understand that the
world is unfair so you have to design a
system that allows for those things to
happen without destroying the system
right and that's one of the things that
individuals that are free can do if you
have decentralizing you should you
understand decentralized uh more than
most people but if you have
decentralized power one person cheating
or taking advantage of someone else or
whatever doesn't ruin the system but if
you have centralized power then the
incentive for the people in charge is to
do whatever the hell they want because
who's going to stop them look at the way
the government's acting now right our
government isn't a communist government
total like it's not a totalitarian
communist government but
the government currently is persecuting
people that have bad opinions because
who's going to stop them you know I was
just thinking we should probably do a
Kickstarter for the Lenin statue
shooting range thing which would
undoubtedly be rejected by Kickstarter
but it would just really be really funny
to have like that video where we're like
you know our plan is to start a business
that brings people together our plan buy
a statue of London and then let people
come to a shooting range where they can
fire guns at it what's this what's the
statue made of bronze bronze okay but
you know we've got a Barrett M82 yeah
and you know we would charge like a
hundred bucks
gotta be at least like 100 yards away no
I think I think if we were going to
allow anyone to fire the M82 at it it'd
have to be like a thousand dollars for
one round Fair because it destroys the
statue like severely and it and you know
like if people are firing 22s at it or
whatever you can go forever and and
enjoy it I wouldn't let him player 22
well unless you're far away because
they're gonna fly out Rickshaw perhaps
just put it in put it with the chickens
because them on Lenin's head is
way better because it will last for
eternity people can take pictures and
then letting the chickens come in and
you can come and take pictures yeah yeah
and then they're less likely to ban our
Kickstarter but it would still be
hilarious to make the kickstarter video
where it's like your contribution today
what do you get you know for a 10
contribution you get one ticket to come
to Lenin land where you can watch
chickens take a dump on his head well
please don't call it Lynn Land please we
do not need to like no no unless it's
like Lenin sucks land then maybe we can
call it Utopia I was just thinking that
yeah just call it Utopia welcome to
YouTube yeah that's actually funny
you know yeah living in the shitty yeah
chicken shitty and like you have a dog
we can allow your dog to come in and
you're in it for a five dollar fee I
still like Phil doing it more no but you
can too that'd be a good video of just
him yelling like full on
it feels so right from behind the statue
of London so I guess the reason why it's
still up is because it's on private
property and it's privately owned cool
it's been it's been very controversial
with a lot of people saying it's like
putting a klansman up and putting but
they're so ready to get rid of it
we're gonna go to super jets so uh
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member to watch the members
only portion of this show and uh we will
have you guys call into the show
and you can talk to us and our guests
will be good fun but for the time being
Let's uh read your super chats I'm not
your buddy guy says I believe your
theory on 2020 and lockdowns is
challenged by them wanting to
re-implement those measures it wasn't
anger but rather opportunity for fewer
Integrity measures throw in media
hysteria mixed with cult members and you
got willing lone wolves committing fraud
interesting
all right Corey Anderson says where is
Will Chamberlain you need to bring in
lawyers to talk about all this BS where
is will uh Will's a good friend but he
works for Rhonda Santos
so still he does yeah does he want to
work for Ron will
but uh as you all know desantis's
campaign has barred any of their people
from coming on this show so lamb take
that for uh what you will
all right we'll grab some more
Andre to colescu
fun fact
Canada has a mandatory retirement age of
75 for senators and it's useless
after the bill c-18 debacle which has
removed news from meta and Google Canada
has now effectively banned WD-40
beginning 2024 help one really
wow
what do we got James says yo Timmy what
up thanks for joining
Raymond g Stanley Jr says ignorance
rules until illegals are sleeping on
your sidewalks they voted for it and
this is the noble life of democracy Tim
the belief in humanity even though
humanity is a screaming selfish mob
FairPoint yeah we didn't get into the
story uh Eric Adams saying that New York
is doomed it made me feel really good
he's like we got 10 000 immigrants
coming every month this the city can't
handle it it's over and it's just funny
because it's like well you you said if
they voted for you'd make it a sanctuary
City and maintain that policy and you
did and now it's all burning down around
you so you know you you did it to
yourself oop
are you ready for yourself man
uh Bullseye Ben says to New York City
you made your bed now sleep in it that's
right
blah blah blah says watch the vid about
Baldur's Gate with all the wokeness
stuff being at the Forefront I think
being able to get screwed by a bear was
overlooked LOL
yeah was it actually a bear though
because Druids can turn into animals and
stuff
so it's like
it I'm playing Baldur's Gate the
mechanics are awesome
it's a crazy game because you can
literally do anything like you you're
you the main character you can die and
then just play the game without it and
carry on the storyline of somebody else
it's really interesting and and I think
it's a lot of fun
and uh you know it's an interesting
question about these uh
identities in character creation because
if they truly made a game with an open
character creation you could literally
create any character within the confines
of the story's Universe in which case if
it's possible to exist you can make it
so
like you could literally create a
character who's schizophrenic
that's the future of character creation
in video games I gotta buy this game
Baldur's game yeah why
so I can at least know what I guess I'm
talking about isn't this the one you you
and Ian are playing uh Ian yeah Ian play
was playing it first but I guess he
stopped I've been playing it I'm I've
got I've got about six hours in
my biggest problem with it right now so
it's basically Dungeons and Dragons and
so it's a really awesome mechanic that
it's like if you are in combat and you
fire an arrow at someone there it's like
your attack versus their defense or
whatever so there's actually a D20 a
dice roll and stuff like that the
problem I'm having with it is that
the path I'm taking in the game
naturally is charisma and persuasion
meaning I'm I'm succeeding by talking my
way through everything which creates a
problem because my characters are Savvy
but can't fight right right so it's like
I'm in a level seven area with level
with level three dudes and I'm
successfully navigating all of the
conflict through I'm gonna try and talk
away with the dragon but it did right
and hit and then it comes to a point
where there's somewhere where you can't
avoid the conflict and it's like you
instantly lose yeah and I'm like but
come on man if I'm leveling up through
persuasion and Charisma and not focusing
on combat like tell me that before
because I had to go back and reload a
save like 30 minutes practice I'm like
oh okay that's just that's lame design
yeah like I walk I walk out of the I
don't want to give too much of the game
away but I walk out of room and there's
like 12 NPCs instant combat and I'm like
well I'm dead you maybe you need to do
side quests to build up get up to level
four or something that's that that's
fine and I understand understand that
like with most RPGs
but it's just an issue of in most RPGs
as you're progressing through the story
your combat is leveling up and then you
might say ah the next level is a little
high so I better you know level up my
guys but I am leveling up my guys I'm
just leveling them up in other ways and
so it's like you know I'm running into
that wall
but it's fine I get it yeah I just
started it too I'm I'm enjoying it so
far it's like Divinity 2 but less
cartoony if you guys ever played
Divinity Divinity series it's kind of
like a king's quest like a talking crab
with like a crown yeah Larry in studios
whose make Boulders gave three they're
they're earlier two games with a
Divinity and Divinity 2 games and
they're like 98 out of 100 top level
games just like Baldur's Gate top down
isometric but they're more crazy like
you can teleport you know there's tons
of stuff to Baldur's Gates more like
realistic
I am enjoying it
is a lot of fun
uh all right let's grab some more Super
chats trollkins says you should have
Thomas E Woods on the show he's a
historian and podcaster whose work
inspired the music caucus he's a friend
too super knowledgeable but also fun and
conversational Guy Tom Woods is great
look we want to do a culture where
episode debating communism
I'd love to get somebody who lived it
you know I mean to be fair Luke did too
but very briefly Luke I haven't heard
back from Zoltan yet oh that'd be
amazing
like I said you're going to be in Miami
I can definitely introduce you to a
whole bunch I mean that would be super
amazing if we did like uh maybe maybe we
maybe we get something we do like one of
those panels where you get you know you
get 10 people to sit down in chairs and
you ask them questions about what's
going on that'd be super awesome maybe a
lot couldn't do it
while we're down there
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
treadbull says Phil what would you have
said to Hinkle if you were here when he
was well I mean
I'm not here to pick fights with people
like I'm it this is not my podcast so
I'm not I'm going to be polite and stuff
like that uh but I would have trilled
him about property rights and what he
does to what his plan is to do with the
people that dissent because it's always
the same plan kill him I don't I don't
think he's actually a communist though
but we'll see if we have a bigger
conversation
there are people who are young and naive
who are like communism is just when
people take care of each other and we
share our stuff it's like no no no no no
you poor child that's now communism is
somebody's in charge that's the LIE they
tell you so they can kill your family
and steal your stuff yep so but is he
naive or is he just evil and doesn't
understand because I think that you know
ultimately if you are in favor of this
and it you know it always ends in people
starving and people being killed and
stuff you have to be a little evil to
like this to want that I mean it's just
paint it like something yeah they they
paint it like it's how old is he 22.
yeah but I mean come on he's 22 and he's
young and whatever but he's not dumb
right he uh objectively you're into
naive sure there's a difference between
the people who are willfully lying and
the people who have been tricked and are
saying dumb things we can call it the
banality of evil in that they're going
along with it but the thing about Hinkle
is I don't even think he is of the
banality of evil communism there are
people who are like communism is
actually good like I've read Marx it's
like okay you're the banality then
you've got people who know what it
really is and lie to you and that's
that's the malice and the abject but
what he's saying isn't even communism he
was not describing communism at least at
least in our conversation yeah I think
the best thing to do with Hinkle I mean
I guess he's got stuff on the internet
but it it's probably good to go ahead
and just like list off a bunch of things
that typically communism he's talking
he's talking about like regulation
yeah we agreed on that like we had a
similar vision of like socializing
certain aspects of of our governance but
how we get there is like do you want to
use communism to get there do you want
to use like volunteerism to get there
which I I don't know how you guys feel
about that the Libertarians when I was
like volunteerism is the way people will
do it because they want is the way but
like you're saying earlier if you don't
have incentive is it just Capital
because they do nice things for people
because you have an incentive to do it I
mean I think that it's it's a cultural
thing it's it's I mean honestly being a
volunteer is you do have a level of of
um
like you do it for your own well-being
you don't do things for other people for
other people you do it for yourself you
feel good when you volunteer I mean I
love to volunteer and I'll be the first
to say it I love to volunteer because it
makes me feel good
I love to do things for other people it
makes me feel good you have to be a
little bit of a selfish person even to
to give to other people I mean there's
an incentive to do it
anything yeah sorry well think you know
uh we talked about Tom Wood's uh I heard
him talking about this one time there's
this odd thing that happens when you
purchase something right you go to the
store and you give them money and and
give they give you the thing or whatever
and you both say thank you
like
that's one of the that's very rare where
both people are thanking each other
because that both people feel like they
have had a good experience in the
exchange right you wanted the thing more
than you than you wanted the money and
the people that had the thing want the
money more than the thing right and that
filling the need of another person is
part of of what makes
uh it markets work the fact that
you have the ability to fill a need and
they can pay you which is that that
positive exchange that's why markets
work and that's one of the things that's
very pro-social about about markets that
just doesn't exist in command economies
like a socialist system there's no thank
you when you just have it you know you
you go in and get your ticket or if
you're sitting in a breadline for for
hours and stuff to get you know just the
basics and stuff so that's one of the
things about volunteerism is both people
are engaging because they want to in a
voluntary way and both people come out
feeling like they got at least a decent
deal or both people come out feeling
like they got screwed and that's how you
know that you got a good deal too if
you're if the guy you did business with
feels like you you took them and you
kind of feel like the guy took you well
then you probably got a fair deal you
know all right the tax vet says the
Trump flag shown is obviously speaking
about the U.S not individuals that's why
it shows 1776 they're saying Trump to
win or America is dead it seems fairly
obvious because that's what everyone's
been saying I agree with that
I'd say Trump to be freed Trump to not
be facing this yes Trump to win is a
whole other scenario I mean is he the
best candidate I mean put it to a vote
right but to say that he has to win I
think that's taking it to the next level
I think it should be Trump to be free of
these charges uh otherwise America is in
a bad place sure I can agree to that I
don't think that he has to then that's
starting a whole other thing so if Trump
doesn't win does that give you an excuse
to now go out and Riot I mean come on
like isn't that how we got here in the
first place like is one step at a time
people let's let him be free let's you
know let's let the system work itself
Pablo papano says Ian no president can
unite the U.S only God and graphene
hey God's a big part of it and
graphene's awesome because that'll give
us a unified like an industrial Focus as
a nation I I actually agree with that I
think at this point
there I don't think there's any
politician that could actually unite the
United States no uh I do think there is
something to be said about God uniting a
people
I don't see I don't see how you create a
culture of faith in the United States
today
but if I if you were to look back at the
past United States people hated each
other and they fought politically but
they all at least shared a moral
framework and that is their faith and
because of that
you know there was cohesion yeah it was
Judaism Islam and Christianity all
focusing on a universe this this one God
a shared moral framework creates
stability and it doesn't matter who your
political leader is if everyone has the
same morals they fear if I do something
wrong I will be punished by someone else
and so it's interesting that faith in a
God or religion that has
punishment for bad Deeds means you're
not going to be the liar the cheater the
stealer because there is someone who is
coming to punish you yeah it doesn't
need to be a president but I think a
human that can translate the ideas of
God and graphene or something you know
whatever it is that unifies the people
if someone can translate that to the
people Gandhi he wasn't the president of
India he was just a guy he's just a
lawyer but he rose to the occasion and
inspired people to free themselves
neglectful sausage says Tim pool smoking
that copium quote they're ramping up
arrests and putting people on the right
end for 20 years they're totally losing
JFC yup I think you'd have to be fairly
naive not to understand the point of
what's going on they're a thing called
things called Death throws do you guys
know what death throws are yeah when
someone begins to die they begin
violently thrashing well not everybody
uh when someone is drowning what do they
do they violently thrash about if
someone is drowning and you go to rescue
them what do they do they grab you and
drag you down that's why they say you
have to go up behind them there's like a
technique for rescuing people who are
drowning there's a way for them
uh that's one technique I don't know I'm
I'm not a lifeguard but uh here's the
thing
if they were in control they would not
need to indict Donald Trump at all if
they were in control they would not need
to put Enrique atario in prison they
they'd simply shut everything that
they'd cut his bank account they'd
destroy his life they tried all that it
didn't work
the proud boys famously got debanked
Enrique tario can continued to do
everything he did it's more like the
economic Hitman stories you know first
they say join us and they say we're
going to pay you off then they start
hurting like hurting you and then they
come in and remove you
but what's happening now with these
cultural victories across the board I
mean come on man look at Rumble the
expansion that they've had
look at Public Square
if if everything keeps moving in this
direction the old school uniparty
machine ceases to exist in a couple
Generations
they're only options now after
everything else has failed censorship
failed debanking failed their only thing
left is violence do you think and even
that's not gonna work that a
decentralized form of governance in the
United States could compete with the
Chinese Communists excuse me centralized
party absolutely
absolutely I mean think about it if this
country was that Beacon of Freedom
that's why everyone wants to be here
anyways even though we're not because we
are you know we do have that like one of
the the things I've thought about this
is is why don't we have an Elon Musk in
Latin America why is it that only the
United States has these people coming
here with all these great ideas and
starting these great companies it's that
freedom that brings people here you want
the best from around the world to come
here you want the best Minds here in the
United States you will beat everybody
else we need that Innovation we want
that Innovation we should be welcoming I
mean it feel however you want to feel
about immigration I'm not going to
debate it but
um if you had a policy where you hey all
of those people who in Venezuela Cuba
whatever that are those great thinkers
that are those great doers why wouldn't
you want them here they're trying to
flee why wouldn't you want them here why
do you want them to go to Russia to
China or anywhere else you want them
here in the United States giving those
great ideas and you know yes I think
that a decentralized country could
I mean that is how the United States
became the United States yeah I get it
so less less Federal Authority allows
for more privatization of and wealth
gain growth which can is more makes you
more resistant to a foreign Nation it's
actually the wealth of the name my
generation I went from using a telephone
on the wall because we had a monopoly
with Ma Bell and as soon as that that
government control of it went away look
at us now we have these little devices
in our hands this is in my generation
it's just so absurd how much government
control just keeps us down and we keep
asking for more of it how much
Innovation and Technology would we be at
if we didn't have the government
stifling us to open a business you have
to go through all these rigmar rules
just to get it started why
you know it's just it's ridiculous the
government does not help you in any way
shape or form some proprietary
um monopolies can be can be really
destructive and like if Google were to
try and take over the world right now
alphabet like we would need our
government to help protect us at least
on America take over the world if there
is no government making them the only
people doing things com competitors
happen all the time go I I know I mean I
still use Google but DuckDuckGo you have
Solutions you cannot have a monopoly
where there is a free market well you
could have big players in the free
market collude sure and kind of Monopoly
BlackRock Vanguard BlackRock is
absolutely using the United States
government to get to where they want to
be do you think they'd be in the worst
place without the US government or
stronger I mean depends on where you're
what your worst or better is I think
they're in a position that is not
favorable to the people of the United
States and they got there using
government the thing about large
corporations is uh Ian for instance you
mentioned MSNBC with a lag yeah they
invest ridiculous sums of money into
this this Foundation they build a
machine that's hard to move as time
progresses their methodologies and
Technologies become are more and more
obsolete or archaic and upstart startups
become disruptive and start moving in
what we typically see is the government
then create roadblocks to support the
jobs by propping up failing Industries
so in not every circumstance but there
are many circumstances where
we'd be better off if these systems were
allowed to collapse and crumble into
themselves
so you you have companies that should
have failed the Auto industry crumbled
from from their own errors you have the
banking industry but then you look at
government programs these things should
be better handled by uh non-profits
I have no problem with social programs
the problem I have is they're not
allowed to fail once social programs run
out don't work anymore they should
whenever any program is created should
have a sunset closed this is for five
years and it's done
instead you get these welfare programs
they keep putting Band-Aids over and
tape over and it keeps making a bigger
and bigger system they can't fail and it
gets broken and worse and it's just in
facts and it gets it there's there's
problems there but let's read some more
Super chats gotta read this one from
Christy Harris
she says Ian I adore you please consider
Trump was more divisive due to things
that about him and not by him he could
not be liked so others deep State fueled
hate however he was a clap back Master
I.E Rosia yeah yeah they they the the
fan the the Flames were fanned I won't
deny that the media did play a huge part
in the back and forth but so did Don
like telling Hillary Clinton he was
gonna would have her arrested and thrown
in jail while he was campaigning yeah
it's way worse that they're actually
arresting people and throwing things I
know but like you open up he opened up
the gate for I that's my opinion by
saying that on stage like for a power
play it's like what are you what are you
messing with bro all right Mia culpa 632
says I invite you and all of the timcast
crew to come to Mountaineer in
Martinsburg on Sunday at 2PM for a
friendly dark luck of the draw building
relationships with the local community
uh perhaps I will be there
I don't know for sure what we're doing
uh what what the plans are this weekend
but um that's the Mountaineer in
Martinsburg we got a bunch of stuff
happening in Martinsburg ladies and
gentlemen uh
I probably shouldn't say it but I'm
gonna say it anyway we were talking
about creating cousin T's a diner and
Papa Jack's Pizza Shack
I think we should do it in Martinsburg
who's uh who's Pizza Shack Papa Jack
was open oh okay all right okay Papa
Jack's Pizza Shack I'm into it with a
skatepark in the back I'm into it oh
that's all right bring the whole family
skate and then eat you know what I think
it'll be super cool an anti-time Square
we create our businesses we've got our
coffee shop we've got cousin T's Diner
we've got Papa Jack's Pizza Shack we get
a my pillow brick and mortar store just
take over a whole like intersection
which is just a street in a downtown
area with all of these businesses that
are the parallel economy we have a bar
that the bar serves Ultra right you know
a conservative dad's Ultra right beer
and um I want to people people will
travel to come hang out and be a part of
this cultural Club they would totally I
was thinking about to do this anti-anti
times it was end times this didn't work
and Times Square Times Circle it doesn't
look good when in writing but we don't
call it anti-time square but that's the
general idea of what it is how cool
would that be and then the thing about
Martinsburg is that it's a couple hours
from a bunch of different metros
Pittsburgh Philadelphia is a few hours
away you got DC Baltimore Richmond is a
few hours away Freedom Square
yeah yeah
Freedom yeah Freedom something I mean
there there's a bunch of Freedom squares
all over the place but how cool would it
be you uh you get a hotel you come down
and then you can get breakfast at cousin
Disney World for people who like freedom
but like Times Square because there's no
theme parks or anything but we could put
an arcade you know be super cool I mean
you said a skate park yeah Papa Jack's
Pizza Shack with skate park in the back
yeah don't eat before you skate it's not
it's not really the skate park isn't
really a part of Papa Jack's Pizza Shack
it's just on the other side of the
street you know what I mean and it's
just fun to say
this is really cool then we'll buy the
statue of Lennon and we'll we'll talk
we'll move it we'll move it to New Times
Square I love this look we're in the
bathroom of Newtown Square yeah let's
call it New Times Square yeah put in the
bathroom everyone just because it's like
New Times Square I'm willing to bet that
there are enough people in this space
that would hands down
Martinsburg is not super expensive it's
the fastest growing city in West
Virginia they would easily be like okay
we'll set up we'll set up a shop there
why not just honestly say millions
millions how about how about Jeremy
Hambly sets up a a comic a card shop in
a comic shop gaming and all that stuff
so now we've got the makings of you know
five different business we got to get a
my pillow brick and mortar store super
easy to do because the inventory doesn't
expire
isn't Eric July from the uh DC area too
is he out here that would be sick though
oh yeah yeah a comic shop with Eric July
will be awesome not to throw more stuff
on his plate the guy's going nuts as it
is because of all the business he's got
but yeah but we can figure this out so
we're talking with Chef Andrew girl
because uh that was uh actually Terence
Williams idea and I'm like that's a good
idea I hit him up right away and he was
like let's roll and I'm like this is
gonna be amazing we're gonna have our
own parallel economy and our own
cultural Hub where we do events we have
comedians we're going to have at our
venue a small stage for comedy and stuff
we have like Ryan long to stand up let's
block off the street and have like block
parties we could we could every Sunday
or something well we can't just do that
that's going to be like you know we got
to talk to them yeah yeah with the city
and everything we could shut it down and
do street festivals on Sundays but I'm
thinking it's one thing that we can we
can do is with uh
with our coffee shop in the small stage
we have we could easily get big bands we
could afford to pay them to come out and
make this a big attraction you could
play outside I don't know of any uh any
venues in the west I don't know where in
West Virginia there are venues I'm sure
that there's at least one I'm not
talking 100 I'm not talking to 200
people I'm talking like a 75 person
Coffee Shop acoustic set yeah Secret
show style sure but we can wear as like
a small coffee shop normally wouldn't be
able to pay major label bands we could
do that for the purpose of bringing
people to our space and then they go get
dinner at Papa Jack's Pizza Shack they
they get a hotel room next morning they
wake up and they go to cousin T's Diner
oh dude this would be the coolest thing
ever yeah we got to make it happen we
need to build a hotel there too they're
they're always know anybody at the
Hilton but I I this I think this would
be just good for everybody I I I I
wonder what the people there uh so what
I do know is that locals
this because we're working there already
yeah and we've had a bunch of people ask
us like can you please invest and help
build this stuff up and uh I think it'd
be really cool if we brought these
parallel economy businesses
and brought them in we could probably
just go down the list of Public Square
and be like if you're a company on
Public Square how would you like to
let's do this so be super cool
well we're going to be doing at the very
least we're going to be uh I've been
talking to Jack posovic about a family
Pizza chain for a long time because you
know his big thing is Pizza Hut
nationalism Family Pizza rest but but
it's like it makes a good point like
there's this viral video of 1989 a Pizza
Hut and it was a bunch of people coming
and having a birthday party and it's
like when do we do this anymore
oh it was so fun that was the difference
Man pizza now is a a strip mall small
store that does delivery only
now we need places where people come
together
I look at GameStop and I went to
GameStop the other day and I'm like dude
this is the best is the wrong business
model GameStop needs to dedicate a third
of its store to competitions community
events
and and tabletop games GameStop should
be a place where you could it it should
be the the Big Chain for for tabletop
games and video game competitions you
should be able to like why is it
why do you need the product why do you
need the best controller why do you need
the best headset oh bro because the
insert video game competition is going
to be held at your local GameStop Friday
night and you can win 50 bucks in store
credit you can or you can go to
Nationals or you can be you know get
into these leagues or whatever
if you're playing video games Esports
competitively what's your local Hub
GameStop could do that I've been saying
that for years but that's just me what
do you think for Jack's Pizza Shack
objects what do you think about Daddy
Jack's Pizza Shack
I think Papa Jack's Pizza Shack works
better it's a bit more literate and
Daddy's kind of sexual so I get it
but Papa's already Papa John was used
for Papa John's I think Daddy is only
sexual in certain contexts because I've
heard the word daddy a whole lot okay
where it was time uncle uncle Jack's
Pizza Uncle Jack's Pizza Shack well Papa
jacket
Papa Jack's neighbor
neighbor
it's already smashed that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really do like it and head over
to timcast.com click join us become a
member of the members only uncensored
shows coming up in a few minutes you
don't want to miss it you can follow the
show at timcastirl everywhere you can
follow me personally at timcast Martha
you want to shout anything out uh like I
said I'm in starting a new business and
it's a Delta eight it's a completely
different way of consuming uh
cannabinoids and so we're starting with
Delta eight and we will have more soon
if you want to check us out ourgood.com
I am uh Phil Labonte you can follow me
on Twitter at Phil that remains or if
you want to call it X that's fine too
you can follow me on Instagram uh I am
at Phil that remains official the band
is All That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify and apple music and YouTube and
Amazon and you know the internet pothead
over here speaking of pothead oh I I
maybe I didn't tweet you out earlier
your Twitter people my Twitter is at
Bueno for Miami and that's my handle for
pretty much all social media um I'm
looking forward I want to talk it's our
good o u r g o o d that is correct
hourgood.com I'll ask you about it on
the after show a little bit I want to
hear about this Delta nine stuff do you
want to try it let's uh every day let's
talk to uh Carter you want to shout
something up yeah I know I'm pumped to
be on today because uh we just wrapped
up a music video as you all know Ian's
in it uh well maybe you don't know but
it's coming out very soon so follow Tim
cast songs
um you can follow me at Carter banks on
Twitter and uh yeah all right everybody
we will see you all over at mcast.com
thanks for hanging out